[موسيقى]
بماذا اخبرك الرئيس العراقي الراحل عن
قتاله شخصيا في شوارع بغداد القوات
الامريكيه وماذا حقق في ذلك اخبرني انه
عند جامع ام الطبول اعطى الدبابتين
امريكيه
واعترض على هذا السلاح العربي المحمول على
الكتف واعترض المرحوم الطاهر في رمضان
على الرئيس قال هذا تصرفك يعني
ما يعني انت قائد انت مو جندي حتى تقاتل
وبعدها انه لازم تبقى يعني
اوامر وليس ان تترك نفسك لتصاب او تقتل
بالضبط وممكن جندي امريكي
واختل ميزان المعرض
هل تاكدت دكتور خليل من الرئيس العراقي
الاسبق بخصوص المعركه التي تحدثت معلومات
انه قتل فيها
الفاع عنصر من القوات الامريكيه ولكن هناك
معلومات تقول ان القوات الامريكيه غطت على
هذا الموضوع وان الرئيس العراقي الاسبق
كان مشاركا في هذه العمليات نعم اخبرني
مشاركه فعاله من قبل في هذه المعركه معركه
المطار
واشترك ايضا هو طبعا سلاح الارض من سفن
واكد في احد المرات
كان يعني
اثناء زيارتي له
قبل الجلوس كنا واقفين انا الرئيس الله
يرحمه والجنرال
[موسيقى]
الامريكي واليام ستيل فصار حديث يعني
سالني كيف الوضع قلت له يعني الامريكان
سلموا العراق لايران فكان عصبي وكان يحكي
جنرال قال له اتحداكم تعلنوا عن الشعب
الامريكي وللعالم ان تعلنه عن خسائركم
اللي بلغت اكثر من 2000 جندي ماريس من
خيره القوات قتلت من القوات العراقيه خلال
معركه المطار خلال معركه المطار وطبعا ما
جاوبوا هذا القائد
[موسيقى]